[Applaus]
[Musik]
seien wir doch mal ehrlich ein jahr nach
dem ausbruch von kogit sind wir alle zu
pandemie biologie wave technologie
epidemiologie und auch vakzine logi
experten geworden oder hat hier
irgendjemand noch nie eine diskussion
über impfstoffe pcr tests oder die
herkunft des corona virus geführt aber
auch wenn wir alle denken alle corona
impfstoffe beim vornamen zu erkennen
wenn ich mir sicher dass du in diesem
video doch noch etwas neues entdecken
wirst oder hast du schon mal was von dem
fußweg chinesischen impfstoff gehört
also die rede ist von einem stoff der in
usbekistan unter dem namen zmz wachs
2001 registriert wurde
aber keine sorge denn heute werden wir
uns nicht mit biochemie beschäftigen was
mich interessiert ist diese merkwürdige
beziehung china und wo sie billig ist
warum haben sich gerade diese staaten
entschieden ein impfstoff gemeinsam zu
produzieren was genau ist dass diese
beiden länder verbindet nun in diesem
video haben wir über eine menge dinge zu
sprechen über die in unseren
kulturkreisen und info babels nur sehr
sehr wenig bekannt ist
und wir werden nicht nur über usbekistan
sprechen
wir begeben uns in einem teil der welt
in dem alle beschlossen haben ihren
länder nahmen die gleiche änderung zu
geben genau die rede ist von kasachstan
usbekistan kirgistan tadschikistan und
turkmenistan ganz genau
wir befinden uns in zentralasien diese
regierung befindet sich schon seit dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert im visier der
großmächte und heute ist da nicht viel
anders heutzutage konkurrieren russland
die vereinigten staaten die türkei
indien pakistan und natürlich china um
einfluss in dieser region über die
unsere mainstream medien zumeist rein
gar nicht berichten
dafür interessieren sich andere umso
mehr für sie peking investiert seit
jahren in den stars es braucht
infrastruktur schickt facharbeitskräfte
und kontrolliert einen sehr hohen
prozentsatz der auslandsschulden dieser
länder
und genau das dürfen wir uns jetzt mal
näher anschauen was martina in
zentralasien
wer profitiert davon und wird diese
region der welt zum neuen expansions-
feld des wieder empor strebenden große
chinesische reichs also sagt sie bereit
gut dann lasst uns sofort loslegen
[Musik]
eine ungleiche beziehung wie du
vielleicht schon vermutet werden wir in
diesem video viel über geld sprechen
und diesbezüglich über die wohl am
gewaltigsten klaffende schere der welt
zum beispiel wird niemand von euch
überrascht sein wenn ich sage dass
chinas bruttoinlandsprodukt 50 mal so
hoch ist wie das aller
zentralasiatischen länder
zusammengenommen china mit tadschikistan
zu vergleichen ist wie von der torte und
einem krümmel zu sprechen aber wieder
wissen gäbe es ohne krümmel keine torte
und umgekehrt sie unterhalten also auf
eine besondere art und weise eine innige
beziehung und natürlich ist es alles
andere als ungewöhnlich dass
nachbarländer ebenso auf die eine oder
andere art handelsbeziehungen
unterhalten nur in diesem fall sind die
beziehungen alles andere als ausgewogen
china ist einer der wichtigsten
investoren und gläubiger zentralasiens
es verfolgt seine interessen knallhart
und sein größtes interesse in dieser
region liegt im energiesektor
chinesische firma wild kasachisches
wasserkraftwerk bauen chinesische exim
bank vergibt creditplus britische bank
für modernisierung von wasserkraftwerken
und das ist noch lange nicht alles denn
während roosters später ansehen aber ich
kann dir jetzt schon sagen dass mehrere
routen der neuen seidenstraße genau
durch zentralasien führen peking baut
und finanziert auch die transport
infrastruktur wie straßen und
eisenbahnen die es braucht um den
transport seiner produkte zu
gewährleisten
er denke aber dass wir über länder mit
sehr schwachen oder gar keinen
demokratischen strukturen sprechen in
denen die korruption einfach mit
absoluter macht regiert oftmals findet
das geld also sogar in den offiziellen
statistiken selbst aus diesem grund sind
ausländische investitionen eine sehr
riskante wette und selbst china hat sich
schon mehr als einmal damit verbrannt in
letzter zeit hat es sich auf kleinere
projekte konzentriert einige fabriken
und zementwerke oder minen die gold
kupfer zink und andere natürliche
ressourcen abbauen
andererseits finanziert peking auch den
bau von schulen und hochschulen in
diesen ländern an denen dann chinesisch
belehrt wird es eröffnet konfuzius
institute in der ganzen region und hat
sogar mehrere stipendien programm
aufgelegt damit zentralasiatische
studenten in china studieren können dies
ist ein klassisches beispiel
chinesischen soft power die neue form
des chinesischen einflusses die wir am
besten noch nicht kennen
die dicken aber mit aller
entschlossenheit nach und nach über den
ganzen globus ausrollt insgesamt hat
china in den letzten 15 jahren 65
milliarden dollar für investitionen und
bauvorhaben in zentralasien
bereitgestellt und das ist ungefähr so
viel wie das gesamte
bruttoinlandsprodukt usbekistans aber du
wächst ist vielleicht dass es bei der
beziehung zwischen zentralasien und
china nur um geld geht nun die wahrheit
ist dass sie noch etwas anderes gemeint
haben ihre leidenschaft für technologie
und kontrolle
sag mal welchen namen würdest du am
projekt geben dass auch ständiger
überwachung inklusive gesichtserkennung
basiert nun in feinster manier heißt es
dort sichere städte ich weiß nicht ob du
diese art von idee markt aber ich kann
dir genau sagen wer sie liebt
tadschikistan und usbekistan entwickeln
bereits ihre safe cds in zusammenarbeit
mit huawei offensichtlich bedeutet
sicherheit auch die totale absicherung
der machtansprüche der herrschenden
bonzen und um bei der tg stunts und
bleiben können wir einen weiteren aspekt
in seinen beziehungen zu china nicht
ignorieren militärische präsenz im
unwirtlichen hochland zentralasiens gibt
es einen stillen neuankömmling
chinesische truppen du weißt
wahrscheinlich schon dass china
militärbasen in dschibuti und im
südchinesischen meer unterhält aber die
in tadschikistan ist die kings erst in
zentralasien und sie hat mit der
absicherung der afghanischen grenzregion
zu tun schon einmal diese karte du
blickst gerade auf die dreifach grenze
zwischen china pakistan und afghanistan
in vakant korridor und die erste
chinesische militärbasis in zentralasien
befindet sich auf taktische gebiet ganz
in der nähe dieses punktes die mag das
vielleicht nicht so wichtig erscheinen
aber für china stellt ist eine
meilenstein da bis jetzt beschränkten
sich die beziehungen mit den staaten der
region auf die wirtschaft aber chinas
einfluss wächst unaufhaltsam und jetzt
wird es eine ganz neue rolle
in den letzten monaten hat peking keine
gelegenheit verstreichen lassen seinen
einfluss in zentralasien mit einer neuen
art von diplomatie zu stärken
der impfstoff diplomatie wie sich
vielleicht erinnert haben wir zu beginn
des videos über den usbekischen
impfstoff gesprochen der von den
chinesischen biopharma unternehmen an
häusern kommen und der chinesischen
akademie der wissenschaften entwickelt
wurde
und du fragst dich es wahrscheinlich
wenn beide institutionen chinesisch sind
was hat dann usbekistan mit der ganzen
sache zu tun nun an dieser stelle
beginnt der interessante teil muss mit
christan war eines jener länder die an
den versuchen mit diesem stoff
teilgenommen haben
so wie zum beispiel auch ecuador und
pakistan im februar 2021 passierte dann
aber folgendes das chinesische
unternehmen hat muss wie gestern als
mitautor bei der entwicklung des
impfstoffs zf 2001 anerkannt usbekistan
wurde also offiziell zum core entwickler
des impfstoffs erklärt dank richtet ihre
seinem beitrag und seine anstrengung wir
wissen nicht ob pakistan ecuador sich
nicht nur mühe gegeben haben aber es
dauerte weniger als zwei wochen ist die
folgende nachricht als nicht kam und
pakistan genehmigt den von china
entwickelten impfstoff gegen kuwait 19
es war das erste zentralasiatische land
chinesischen impfstoff in eine zulassung
erteilte und ihnen damit das tor in die
region öffnete schon bald darauf haben
kann dieses dann und turkmenistan
sinopharm ebenfalls zugelassen und
tadschikistan wartet darauf seien sie
nowak zu erhalten in zentralasien dreht
sich zunehmend alles und china
warum also ist china so interessiert an
zentralasien und umgekehrt was erwarten
die stars vom asiatischen riesen also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
das kleingedruckte
als regelmäßiger zuschauer von visual
politik bist du bereits bestens darüber
informiert dass peking heute eine ganz
andere aussenpolitik fährt als noch vor
50 jahren
tja so ist das halt wenn ein land ist
dessen wirtschaft in die höhe geschossen
ist wie eine rakete
nun war es zentralasien trifft ganz
china dort in den 1990 er jahren an
bedeutung zu gewinnen erinnert sich
daran dass die stunts bis 1991 teil des
sowjetunion waren und in deren endzeit
ließen sich diese politischen
beziehungen viel zu wünschen übrig von
diesem zeitpunkt an musste p die
grundlegenden probleme mit seinen neuen
nachbarn lösen wie man die grenzen sieht
oder was man mit den bürgerkrieg in
tadschikistan macht aber die wichtigste
veränderung kam in den 2000er jahren als
china begann die enorme menge an dollars
die es dank seines riesigen
handelsüberschusses anhäufte weltweit zu
investieren so nämlich auch in
zentralasien
aber warum genau in zentralasien nun im
grunde aus drei gründen
einerseits china eine mehr als 3000
kilometer lange grenze mit kasachstan
kirgisistan und tadschikistan und hat
auch sonst viel mit den ländern der
region gemeinsam so bestand etwa ein
promille der bevölkerung chinas in den
frühen neunziger jahren aus kasachen
tadschiken usbeken und kirgisen
auf der anderen seite verbraucht china
seit 1993 mehr energie als es selbst
produziert das heißt es muss sie
importieren so sind die stars zu einer
wichtigen quelle pekings für öl und gas
geworden und dritter könnte china im
jahr 2013 die schaffung der einen neuen
seidenstraße damit wurde zentralasien so
einer wichtigen territorialen route und
chinesische produkte mit europäischen
märkten zu verbinden aber da ich denke
dass dies mehr oder weniger klar ist
lasst uns zur nächsten frage nie
übergehen
wie profitiert zentralasien von einer
beziehung mit china
[Musik]
wenn du siehst hier sollte
berücksichtigt werden das macht dem
zusammenbruch der udssr die stars zu den
ersten ländern im gesamten
postsowjetischen raum wurden
jahrzehntelang hatten sie hochgradig
verletzte produktionssysteme und waren
im grund monokultur volkswirtschaften dh
sie waren hochgradig spezialisiert auf
einige wenige produkte die sie im großen
stil produzierten um den rest der story
republiken damit zu versorgen aber dann
brach das alles ja in sich zusammen
andererseits wenn nur alle probleme
zentralasiens wirtschaftlicher natur
wären leider ist das aber nicht der fall
denn mit ausnahme von kirgisistan sind
sie auf politischer ebene allesamt
negativ beispiele für elster
demokratisierung wir sprechen über
regimes die führer zentriert arbeiten
und sich nicht um menschenrechte kümmern
nimm doch die endemische korruption
hinzu und du hast ein ziemlich gutes
bild von einer region in die nur wenige
investieren wollen deshalb kam ich mir
das finanzspritze ist das zentrale asien
wie manna vom himmel vor allem für die
ganzen autokraten denn das geld
ausgegangen war nicht an politische
reformen oder ähnliche bedingungen
gebunden außerdem konnten die
zentralasiaten durch die entwicklung
neuer straßen und gaspipelines in den
osten kinetischen geld ihre historische
abhängigkeit von russland reduzieren
gut bis jetzt mag das ganze wie die
perfekte beziehung aussehen aber denk
dran immer das kleingedruckte zu lesen
in dieser ehe diktiert china ganz
eindeutig die bedingungen
[Musik]
das hat zur folge dass viele verträge
den einsatz chinesischer maschinen die
beschäftigung genetischer facharbeiter
und im falle möglicher streitigkeiten
als gerichtsstand natürlich china
vorschreiben und natürlich reden wir
über ein china das nicht gerade darum
wird ein privates darlehen zu sein
angefangen bei den arbeitsbedingungen
die oft geradezu unerträglich sind
glaube also nicht dass alles in butter
ist allein in den letzten zwei jahren
hat die region mehr als sage und
schreibe 40 demonstrationen gegen die
chinesische expansion erlebt und
manchmal hatten diese proteste direkte
konsequenzen
das wolle china geführte 280 millionen
dollar projekt in kirgisistan wurde nach
protesten aufgegeben
auf jeden fall wächst die anti
chinesische stimmung in kasachstan und
kirgistan wo etwa ein drittel der
bevölkerung eine negative meinung über
den roten riesen hat im gegensatz dazu
genießt china in den beiden ländern mit
denen es keine gemeinsame grenze hat
viel ansehen
das ist wie gestern und minister
natürlich hat die öffentliche meinung in
dieser region der welt keinen extra
großen einfluss auf die offizielle
position der potentaten und wenn china
etwas gewonnen hat dann sind es die
herzen der erlebten du verstehst sich ja
das mangelnde transparenz ein großer
verbündeter der korruption ist oft gibt
es keine möglichkeit zu wissen wie viel
geld unterwegs vom laster fällt mit
anderen worten chinas riesige
kreditlinie ist vor allem sehr gut für
die polizei in zentralasien deren
oberste prämisse ist erstmal in jedem
projekt ihren anteil einzusacken und das
ist mitunter ein grund warum diese
projekte oft nicht ganz wie erwartet
funktionieren
tja und irgendwann kommt dann
schließlich auch der zeitpunkt an dem
die kredite zurückgezahlt werden müssen
china er lässt keine schulden
in der wirtschaftswissenschaft sind
auslandsschulden alle verpflichtungen
die ein staat mit anderen ländern oder
mit ausländischen institutionen hat
diese kredite die zum beispiel von der
ex im bank of china der export-import
bank chinas vergeben werden sind für die
länder die diese kredite erhalten
auslandsschulden und wie du dir
vorstellen kannst gibt es kein einziges
zentralasiatisches land das sich china
gegenüber schuldenfrei wäre peking
kontrolliert ganze 42 prozent der
kirgisischen auslandsschulden 40 prozent
der tschechischen 20 prozent der
usbekischen center kasachischen was
durch ministern angeht können wir keine
daten nennen da öffentliche statistiken
nicht gerade die kernkompetenz des
dortigen regimes darstellen klar ist
aber dass die am meisten verschuldeten
länder auch die beiden ernsten in der
region sind krisen und tadschikistan und
du fragst dich vielleicht warum leiht
china so viel geld an länder die es
vielleicht nie werden zurückzahlen
können nun in der welt der
internationalen beziehungen gibt es
theorien für alles
so hat zum beispiel der akademiker
braucht marcellini vor vier jahren seine
eigene vorgestellt und sie
schuldenfallen diplomatie genannt auf
den punkt gebracht besagt sie dass china
gar nicht erwartet die kredite die es
unter entwickelten ländern anbietet auch
zurückbekommen stattdessen beabsichtigt
peking ein geflecht aus politischen
abhängigkeiten zu schaffen das es
ermöglicht sogar die souveränität dieser
staaten infrage zu stellen
natürlich ist dies nur eine theorie
offensichtlich ist china weder der
partei noch ist zentralasien oder
irgendein anderes land der welt dazu
verpflichtet pekings kredit angebote die
man nicht ablehnen kann anzunehmen die
theorie der schuldenfalle diplomatie
besagt ist vereinfacht das form dass die
lokalen eliten von jeglicher
verantwortung frei zu stellen sind
vielleicht ist das größte problem der
perverse anreist die diese art der
korruption erzeugt so etwas wie ich
nehme mir jetzt erstmal meinen anteil
und irgendwie wird das volk und seine
nachkommen irgendwann in zukunft schon
alles abbezahlt nun tatsache ist dass
jedes land nach wegen sucht um mit den
immer größer werdenden chinesischen
schulden fertig zu werden durch
ministern verkauft zum beispiel bars
unter marktpreis und kasachstan das
direkt an chinas dem regieren grenzt
herzlich beim thema der unterdrückung
von uiguren einfach mal zurück aber die
vielleicht interessanteste celestini von
tadschikistan und kirgisistan für diese
beiden länder ist einer der häufigsten
wege die schulden an china zurück zu
zahlen die abtretung der rechte zur
ausbeutung natürlicher rohstoffe und das
ist dann der grund so nachrichten wie
die folgende pakistan ratifiziert die
übertragung von goldminen an chinesen
heute sind ganze 80 prozent der
tadschikischen goldminen unter der
kontrolle chinesischer unternehmen aber
nicht nur das es gibt gerüchte dass
tadschikistans zögern der eurasischen
wirtschaftsunion unter führung russlands
beizutreten genau auf den druck pekings
zurückzuführen ist und dass die
dürftigen nun im jahr 2011 hat definitiv
das griechische parlament ein neues
protokoll zur grenzziehung ist wodurch
china mehr als 1000 quadratkilometer im
pamir gebirge erhielt das sind fast ein
prozent des gesamten territoriums
tadschikistans china er lässt seine
schulden wahrlich niemandem
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese situation ist sogar noch schlimmer
wie in den anderen zentralasiatischen
ländern ist auch seine wirtschaft stark
von überweisungen von im ausland
arbeitenden kirgisen abhängig die mehr
als 30 prozent des bip ausmachen
deshalb war die korona krise und die
damit einhergehenden reisebestimmungen
ein riesiger schlags das land es wird
immer schwieriger die china schulden zu
begleichen die sich ebenfalls auf 30
prozent des bip belaufen und meist du
könntest den offiziellen vorschlag
erraten wenig diesen schulden umzugehen
sei
bist du bereit also hier kommt er konto
für geldüberweisungen zur rückzahlung
von auslandsschulden in kirgisistan
eröffnet ja du hast richtig gehört das
chinesische finanzministerium hat ein
bankkonto eröffnet auf dem jeder zur
bezahlung der auslandsschulden des
landes beitragen kann
der wichtigste punkt ist das ist nicht
das erste mal ist dass dies passiert
schon im jahr 2007 eröffnete auch der
damalige präsident dann bei es eine
ähnliches bankkonto
damals betrugen die auslandsschulden
fast zwei milliarden dollar und was
denkst du wie viel geld er auf dieses
tolle spendenkonto von seinen bürgern
überwiesen bekommen
ich würde sie verraten ganze 3350 dollar
und im jahr 2020 kann aber etwas mehr
zusammen dann 12.000 dollar im vergleich
zu kriegen ist dass außer schulden ist
dass kaum ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein wenn ihr das alles also die ein
witz vorkommt zu hast du vollkommen
recht diese verzweiflungs aktion ist
nichts anderes als ein ausdruck dafür
wie aussichtslos verschuldetes land
gegenüber china ist aber vorerst hat das
land keine andere wahl als eine
abhängigkeit von china noch weiter zu
vertiefen aber was denkst du eigentlich
über diese ganze geschichte was hältst
du von dieser crowdfunding idee wusstest
du über chinas rolle in zentralasien
bescheid ist es möglich von chinas
krediten zu profitieren ohne abhängig zu
werden
teilt eure meinung bitte wie immer mit
uns und auch allen anderen ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat
fasst er gibt uns mit deinen freunden
und vergesst nicht unseren kanal auch zu
abonnieren macht es gut und es bald
[Musik]